There are lots of different ways to solve this problem
and that's true for all programming problems
One of the things I hope you will learn from this class is that you can do experiments
you can try lots of different things.See what works.
And there are often some solutions that will be better than others. But you should always feel free
to try running code in the interpreter to see what happens.
Here is one way to solve this:
We are going to use print and we need an expression that computes the number of
minutes in seven weeks. So we will multiply seven, which is the number of weeks
times 7 days in a week, times 24 hours in a day, times 60 minutes in an hour.
And that will output the number of minutes in 7 weeks.
Let's try that in the python interpreter. Then we run and we get 70560 minutes as
our answer. That seems like a long time.
You can do this course at any pace you want. But it's designed to take most people
about 7 weeks to complete. Some will go faster, some will go slower and that's fine.
What I hope is that by the end of the course, you feel like you can
really write programs to do interesting things
and you've got a great understanding of computer science.
Of course we don't expect you will send all 70000 minutes during those 7 weeks
just working on this course.
You may need to eat, sleep, work a job, go to school, do some other things,
but I hope you will really enjoy the course.